olá eu sou mateus ficou meio óbvio né
eu sou homem branco hétero
cresci em classe média alta cresci em
uma família católica e por que se
importa
os privilégios que eu tive a minha vida
inteira que me trouxeram aqui e eles são
o principal combustível para que o
trilho um caminho de transformação
social e possa devolver para a sociedade
tudo aquilo que eu tive mas eu não vim
falar de privilégios eu não vim falar de
sexualidade
eu não vim falar de igualdade de gênero
nem falar de nada disso
eu acredito que tem gente muito melhor
do que eu para falar sobre isso eu vim
falar sobre a tecnologia eo seu papel
social
antes eu vou apresentar um pouco da
minha vida pra vocês me conhecerem
melhor
eu sou filho de batalhadores por
definição mercadores
mas para minha sorte sonhadores os
sacrifícios que meus pais tiveram para
que eu tivesse tudo que tem hoje
eles me distanciaram das minhas raízes
eles acabaram me tirando um pouco da
minha identidade tanto social quanto
pessoal
e nesse contexto eu trilhei duas dois
caminhos para buscar o que eu queria
aos 17 anos eu entrei na unesp aqui de
bauru cursando é ciência da computação
eu tinha um sonho quando eu entrei que
era de trabalhar com robótica e eu
busquei isso na verdade quando eu era
criança eu me divertia com as histórias
do franjinha e com mauricio de sousa ea
idéia de fazer ciência desde pequeno ela
me agradava muito trabalhar com
tecnologia e foi assim que eu comecei
dentro da unesp a participar do time de
futebol de robôs e definir
novamente começar a trabalhar com
computação avançada
disputei campeonatos de oportunidade de
conhecer muitas pessoas e acabei até
envolvendo um pouco com educação e
acabei trabalhando em alguns projetos de
robótica educacional e educação acabou
se tornando um outro caminho que trilhei
eu fui voluntário de diversas ongs
em uma delas o projeto formiguinha
eu fui durante cinco anos sócio educador
e em dois deles o presidente da
instituição
eu descobri lá que causar um impacto
social é extremamente difícil porém é
muito gratificante você não precisa de
muito para causar impacto no dia a dia
das pessoas
e você ainda consegue sair de lá com
incríveis memórias e sempre grato pelo
que acabou de passar e foram essas duas
esses dois caminhos essas duas
experiências que me colocaram o ideal
profissional que seria trabalhar com
tecnologia avançada e seu papel social
eu vou focar em inteligência artificial
e robótica especificamente no impacto
que essas áreas têm na sociedade daqui
pra frente e pra fazer isso eu gostaria
de desmistificar um pouco a ideia do
robô
quando se pensa em um robô você já
imaginou um ser metálico um ser cheio de
circuitos espostos de fios saindo que
veio do futuro para se matar
e na verdade um robô que pode ser muito
mais simples e ele pode ter propostas
muito nobres educacionais inclusive e eu
não sei se vocês sabiam mas com um papel
e um lápis vocês conseguem ascender led
então é difícil fazer robótica e mesmo
com esses exemplos no nosso dia a dia as
pessoas ainda acham que um robô e
chegada no cambalhota pra acabar com a
humanidade
pelo menos ainda não
e à robótica ela é muito vasta ela não
necessariamente é física e ela está
presente no nosso dia a dia muito tempo
na verdade o termo robô ele é um de
origem de uma palavra sueca quer dizer
trabalho forçado e ele começou a ficar
popular através do trabalho de isaac
asimov um mundo da ficção científica que
aconteceu na década de 30 e a partir
desses trabalhos é que se começou a ter
os conceitos populares de robótica
mas antes disso o ser humano já buscava
formas de automatizar e de criar
máquinas que pudessem facilitar o seu
trabalho e quase sempre bélico e e uma
coisa que é muito interessante todo
mundo principalmente na educação tem
medo de que a tecnologia veio para
substituir alguma coisa veio pensando
que a máquina vai tirar o lugar do homem
de que a máquina uma hora vai estar
palestrando sedex e esse medo ele existe
hoje mas ao tomar automação ela não veio
pra tirar o lugar do homem
na verdade para analisar isso porque são
dados muito são muito duros né você
conversar sobre tecnologia ea
substituição do homem de fato tem um
estudo da consultoria e 15 que diz que
e 50% dos trabalhos dos empregos do
brasil podem ser substituídos por uma
máquina e até 2030 18 milhões de
brasileiros vão ser impactadas pela
automação
eu gosto de pensar que existe uma
ferramenta muito interessante para
analisar esses dados
e eu acredito que ela seja a história a
gente olhar hoje a sociedade como ela
está organizada é um reflexo da
revolução industrial ea revolução
industrial ela já veio com o intuito de
substituir o trabalho artesanal pelo
trabalho de máquina e onde se começou o
trabalho assalariado também
mesmo assim ainda tem muitos trabalhos
que são insalubres são difíceis são
monótonos e que não deveria estar sendo
feito por seres humanos e é e onde a
gente entra na próxima revolução uma
revolução que está na mão da
inteligência artificial que recentemente
foi apelidada como o próximo hitler
mas não se desespere com está e muitos
existem muitas culturas é principalmente
de filmes hollywoodianos e ficção
científica que tratam da inteligência
artificial de forma que a gente debater
esse tema e possa construir algo de
concreto para a sociedade
mas antes de mais nada inteligência
artificial é um campo das ciências
cognitivas
ela busca através do software ou através
do hardware é replicar o conhecimento
humano a inteligência humana
a gente está um pouco distante ainda de
se ter uma máquina inteligente a ponto
de ser um ser humano
mesmo assim a inteligência artificial
ela ainda é uma ferramenta muito
poderosa que tem sido utilizado por
grandes empresas e todas as empresas que
estão donas de si desse tipo de
tecnologia elas conseguem ser líderes de
mercados hoje dominados boa parte deles
e porque eles que eles conseguem porque
a inteligência artificial ela vem pra
manipular uma massa de dados que se
tornou hino
ano de se compreender e de atuar com
esses dados hoje é muito difícil você
interpretar esses dados você sendo o ser
humano ea máquina faz esse papel
são dados que eles poderiam ser
utilizados para muitas coisas para
reduzir a fome para distribuir renda
para ter impacto social e de fato da
igualdade então inteligência artificial
ela vai ter papel fundamental no estudo
por isso que nós temos que discutir
inteligência artificial e robótica como
políticas públicas
ela não pode ficar só na mão de
desenvolvedores na mão de técnicos
chamam de engenheiros
ela tem que ser debatido pela sociedade
e por conta de existir muito medo sobre
o que a inteligência artificial pode
causar principalmente nas frases de
allam manske disse hawkins e de bill
gates que e be vem preocupando com essa
questão da inteligência artificial
principalmente porque ela pode ser
utilizado de forma bélica ela pode ser
utilizada em guerra
nós temos que pensar que uma máquina ela
serve para o propósito pela qual ela foi
enviada e ela serve pelo propósito pela
cola foi criada então ele tem que tomar
cuidado porque existem duas coisas aqui
crescendo em uma tecnologia em a outra
tá sabedoria em utilizar essa tecnologia
hoje com a nossa sabedoria ea nossa
tecnologia nós somos como bebê
segurando uma arma beleza como podemos
evitar essa situação porque o uso da
inteligência artificial
vai depender de você vai depender de nós
vai depender da sociedade debatendo esse
tema
e teve gente que já pensou nisso
já houveram pensadores preocupados com
como a robótica e como inteligência
artificial devem se comportar para a
sociedade
isaac asimov em seu conto o robô
ele cita três leis
que a robótica deve seguir a primeira
lei é um roubo não pode ferir um ser
humano ou por inação permitir que um ser
humano sofra algum mal e parece meio
óbvio até na segunda lei
um robô deve obedecer às ordens que lhe
sejam dadas por seres humanos exceto nos
casos em que tais ordens entre em
conflito com a primeira lei terceira lei
um robô deve proteger a sua própria
existência desde que tal proteção não
entra em conflito com a 1ª ou 2ª leis e
um pensamento muito interessante que ele
traz nesse livro num questionamento é
que se você parar pra pensar o ser
humano ele tem um instinto de
autopreservação de sobrevivência
essa é a terceira lei da robótica um ser
humano bom ele se preocupa em seguir as
regras sociais
ele ouviu o médico dele ele ouviu o
advogado dele ele segue as leis do seu
país mesmo que isso cause desconforto
ele acaba se acostumando com os costumes
de seu o seu local
essa segunda lei para um robô e se você
parar pra pensar um bom ser humano deve
amar o próximo como a si mesmo
deve arriscar sua vida para o próximo e
dedicar se a cuidar dele e essa é a
primeira lei da robótica
então se você parar pra pensar nessas
leis um robô poderia ser só um robô mas
ele também poderia ser só um ser humano
muito bom esses princípios eles são base
de muitas instituições éticas que que
estão na nossa sociedade hoje
e aí tem um questionamento muito
interessante quando se fala de igualdade
quando se fala de problemas sociais
dessa magnitude
existe uma discussão que eu já ouvi
sobre distribuição de renda a onde
existe uma comparação entre duas
profissões e no caso das profissões era
no lixeiro e o médico geralmente a
discussão elas dela se ela seguia no
seguinte argumento porque é que eu vou
querer ser médico se o lixeiro vai
ganhar a mesma coisa que um médico
porque eu queria me esforçar tanto para
fazer medicina
se eu posso ser lixeiro que é muito mais
fácil
a questão é que no futuro o seu cheiro
seu médico não ser um robô que tinham
direito a discutir nesse na verdade o
trabalho do cheiro ele é desumano
ele é desumana ele deveria ser feito por
uma máquina desde sempre e nós não
estamos muito longe disso eu acabei de
comentar
há um tempo atrás foi na quarta feira
agora a fd aqui é o órgão que regula a
saúde nos estados unidos aprovou pela
primeira vez o uso de inteligência
artificial na medicina e no caso eles
usam um software de reconhecimento de
imagem para diagnosticar retinopatias
diabéticas
é um mal que atinge 30 milhões de
americanos hoje
então nós já estamos próximos disso
porque quando você vai pra quando
decidir quando a gente fala sobre
cirurgia quando se fala sobre medicina
você já vai para a mesa de operação com
uma probabilidade de acerto
você já sabe a taxa de sucesso nós já
temos modelos matemáticos muito bem
definidos para medicina e é aí que a
inteligência artificial atua por isso
que com o tempo a gente vai acabar tendo
funções sociais que elas vão ser
substituídas pela máquina mas não porque
o ser humano é descartável
porque aquele trabalho específico não
deveria estar sendo feito por um ser
humano e eu espero que conforme vai
passando o tempo ea gente consiga tarefa
que tarefas monótonas insalubres e
difíceis sejam feitas por robôs que a
gente consiga fazer isso de forma igual
para não propagar mais desigualdade que
existe hoje
e no final das contas quando a gente
conseguir
e que a gente tenha tempo para outras
coisas como artes música e relações
humanas
enfim a gente consiga ter tempo para ser
mais humanos
obrigado
[Aplausos]